when you're first of all welcome uh back
to the studio a draw with the black
pieces against uh Wesley saw the
defending Champion how would you assess
your performance in this game uh yeah I
played pretty solid uh I think uh the
opening was uh very quiet uh at some
point there were some uh chart options
like he could play this E5 uh E5 move
after I played E6 I I believe was
possible
oh yeah here I thought the T5 takes on
F3 yeah Queen F3 and Bishop takes C5
Knight B5 but I thought I can play 97
and
um sacrifice The Exchange and after
Queen A8 for example yeah King D7 takes
takes the Rooks are not doing much and
my knight is going to land on D4 and
um I thought this is this is pretty good
good conversation for you yeah but uh
yeah but mostly of course it's a very
solid opening and then uh uh I think uh
after
um when I when I took only two and and
took on before and played D5 that was
the very solid decision as well maybe
you can play F5 if I really want to give
the tension uh instead of taking no
instead of taking on E2 and on B4 you
skip the Knight on D4 and maybe play F5
and uh it's probably a good position but
I thought that uh what I did was pretty
uh solid and maybe I'm just tiny bit
worse but not really much because we're
getting ambitious during the game did
you think that you have a pool in in not
really I mean I if I wanted to try to
keep the tension then I would go F5 but
I saw the other way and I I saw that I'm
equalizing and and I went for it
um
very concerned at all by this expansion
with H4 uh yeah well I wasn't thinking
about H4 but I thought in general that
he can keep the tension and move like
Rook fd1 or something like that but uh
yeah I thought I can take and and play
Queen C7 or something and and then
eventually we'll be fine but I don't
know maybe why this is a bit better but
I thought it's nothing too serious and I
should be able to to equalize nothing to
be worried about but uh yeah the way we
played I mean Ed of course if Queen F3
here it's nothing to worry about because
I can play Rook AB8 and C5 T4 and this
is six second take on C6 leading to a
draw which hand game
take take this yeah five or
yeah
there is no reason why it would be worse
here
so C5 but uh yeah I have this D4 because
if white is in time to play before then
with this Pawn on on C5 eventually my my
Bishop on B7 could be
um passive and also the the other Bishop
gets close but just in time to play D4
and uh yeah then here I thought I was
just out of danger
and it seemed like he felt the same way
because you guys were kind of already
speeding things up Russia into that
equal position there's no way for either
side to create chances here I believe
yeah
linear how would you assess your
performance up to at this point still
seven rounds to go well it hasn't been
great but it's uh it's not bad either I
I still have some some white games I
already play my games against most of
the top guys so I'll try to use my
chances in the in the rest of the game
especially the wide games especially now
that Fabiano seems to be speeding up in
the tournament it seems to be winning
against elshon as well yeah
of course
when when father is in shape he can
really score like that uh then I mean if
you keep scoring like that there won't
be much of a fight for for the
championship but uh but okay still there
there are some rounds to go and and a
lot of things can happen so
um for for myself I have to try to use
the chances that I that I get and and
try to to press a bit plenty of routes
to go a lot of energy to be spent will
let you recover and we'll see you
tomorrow thank you thank you Lanier